it poses
interesting questions when the sort of
consensus on what is good and bad what
is wrong and what is Right starts to
break down because then the question
becomes how do you justify your moral
codes how do you justify your law codes
well if you don't have a sacred
authority they can only be justified in
terms of themselves and then you move
into a kind of pragmatic world where as
we're seeing emerging around us in
America in the United Kingdom and in
Europe today it tends to become whoever
shouts loudest or whoever has the the
most powerful Lobby group it gets to
determine what the moral code by which
society is to be organized is
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People a
brilliant guest today is a Christian
Theologian and an ecclesiastical
historian who is also the author of The
Rise and Triumph of the modern self Dr
Carl Truman welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me on guys it's great
to be here it's a it's a real pleasure
to have you on the show before we get
cracking I've given you an introduction
you've of course written a fantastic
book uh or many books uh tell everybody
who doesn't know who you are already who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us on yet another podcast as you
explained to us before we started well I
I live in the United States place called
slippery rock which is about uh 40 miles
north of Pittsburgh in Western
Pennsylvania but you can tell by my
accent I was born and brought up in the
UK born in Birmingham grew up in
gloucestershire consider myself a West
country boy I'm a something of a
follower of Gloucester Rugby Club
studied at the University of Cambridge
the classics and then went to University
of Aberdeen where I did a PhD in
Reformation history and taught at the
universities of Nottingham Aberdeen and
then at a place called Westminster
Seminary in in Philadelphia emigrated
here in 2001. primarily my work has been
in in Reformation history but five or
six years ago due to things going on in
the the township where I live near
Philadelphia I got sort of pulled into
the whole transgender issue which lies
partly behind the the books I've I've
written more recently and so I I guess
now I spent very little time on
ecclesiastical history and most of my
time uh talking on very Politically
Incorrect topics with with guys like
yourself married two kids one grandchild
that's fantastic we're very happy to
hear that uh but you mentioned the the
trans issue and I hope people aren't at
this point going well this is going to
be another conversation about the trans
we've had plenty of those I think
everybody knows what they think about it
at this point really I don't want to
talk to you about that but the reason I
think that people like you are really in
demand at the moment certainly from
People Like Us is Francis and I have
always been fascinated by history and I
I do feel that historical perspective
gives us has a certain explanatory power
for things that are happening in the
present and your book the Triumph of the
self you know the modern self rather it
really talks about uh our
self-perception changing over time and
how we view ourselves changing over time
sure the trans conversation is part of
it but it seems to me that actually what
you're talking about is the entire world
view that we as human beings have of
ourselves has changed in a dramatic way
what has been that change and what has
caused it in your opinion
yeah it's a great question and I think
one of the things that a lot of people a
lot of the mistakes a lot of people
makes we we tend to view things like the
trans issue in isolation we don't set it
against a broader background of things
that have been happening over a long
period of time particularly uh in in the
west uh again I know you don't want to
keep on the transition but just reflect
on it for a second for for the statement
I'm a woman trapped in a man's body to
make sense we have to have come to a
position in Western Society where we
intuitively give uh inner feelings
tremendous authorities Authority that
even even Aces The Authority the
external authority of our own bodies
so when you look at it that way I think
that the question becomes how have we
reached the point where we see ourselves
so much in terms of our inner feelings
rather than foreign external obligations
why is it that I think of myself as as
the feelings that dwell within rather
than my connection to my location to my
family uh to my ancestors to my employer
to my local community all of these
things have become somewhat weaker over
over recent years so the answer the
question is it's because we've come to
authorize those inner feelings how
that's come about is is interesting and
complicated story there's there's an in
what we call an intellectual genealogy
and we can go back and we can look
really from the 16th 17th century
onwards as to how the the emphasis upon
the first person the eye becomes so
significant philosopher like Descartes I
think therefore I am or you could go to
an essayist like montane who's who's the
first real writer in the west who uses
the first person consistently in his
writing uh Rousseau 18th century genevan
philosophy but he's the man who says you
know really you're born free you're born
pristine
it's society that messes you up and it
messes you up by twisting and perverting
your your natural feelings and your
Natural Instincts so we can trace that
intellectual genealogy going back really
to the 16th 17th century most people of
course don't read Montana read Descartes
they don't read Rousseau but when you
think about the messages that the world
around sends to us and how that shapes
our intuitions we can see yeah the the
self the enemy the eye has become more
and more important for for a variety of
reasons say
think of music for example I use this as
an example in class two or three hundred
years ago if you wanted to enjoy music
you'd got to go and be part of a
communal event music was something that
was produced it was not something that
was consumed today
I can plug my headphones into my phone
uh go to Spotify I can choose to listen
to whatever I want to choose to I become
God I become the one who chooses I
decide what makes up my day so the store
is a complicated one it has an
intellectual genealogy it also has for
one of a better term a technological
genealogy as well
and Carl it seems to me that we worship
these things and we don't worship God
anymore and that has created a very real
problem in our society hasn't it
yes I mean it's an interesting question
how how sort of the idea of God fits
into this and one of the things we could
say about traditional societies and I'm
not speaking particularly about
Christian societies here though they
provide good example if you think about
uh uh think about medieval Christendom
or you were to think let's say about the
Ottoman Empire in the Middle Ages uh or
you were to think about the the Jews uh
during the time of the Old Testament all
of those societies are organized along
lines that appeal to a sacred authority
in other words the reason they act and
behave the way they do is grounded in
some Transcendence external Authority
the last two or three hundred years
certainly in the west uh we we've lost
that we've on the one hand we privatized
religion we both live in countries where
you're free to be religious uh you're
not sent to prison for being religious
but we've we've taken that out of the
the Public Square we've taken that out
of the kind of debates that that shape
the moral codes by which we live and on
one hand that has brought great benefits
it means people don't get persecuted for
their religion or their lack of religion
anymore
on the other hand it poses interesting
questions when the sort of consensus on
what is good and bad what is wrong and
what is Right starts to break down
because then the question becomes how do
you justify your moral codes how do you
justify your law codes well if you don't
have a sacred authority they can only be
justified in terms of themselves and
then you move into a kind of pragmatic
world where as we're seeing emerging
around us in America in the United
Kingdom and in Europe today it tends to
become whoever shouts loudest or whoever
has the the most powerful Lobby group it
gets to determine what the moral code by
which society is to be organized is
and also as well what it does is because
you realize that you were going to die
your time on this planet is limited
whereas if you're religious you believe
you're going to go to heaven you're
going to live an everlasting life in
Paradise but the here and now you
realize your time is limited so why
should you endure discomfort why should
you do something that you don't want to
do if life is finite then surely it
should be as pleasurable as possible
until it ends yeah that's a very good
point and I think again there's an
intellectual genealogy to that the the
German philosopher Nietzsche in the 19th
century is wrestling with the question
of well you know uh life is meaningless
so is it also worthless and his answer
that interestingly is no life is
meaningless but that doesn't mean it
isn't worth living you should live every
second as if it's going to come back for
all eternity what he what he really
means by that is
live live in the Here and Now make every
second count and and as you point out in
in your statement there that tends
towards a position where immediate
pleasure becomes king so for example uh
you know why have children my children
even on the great Delights of my life my
granddaughter is now the great after my
wife I have to say that because she
might listen to this after my wife my
granddaughter is the is the most
important woman in my life at this point
uh I'm delighted if you like in in
seeing the future unfolding before me
but if you don't believe that there's
really any future worth working towards
why bother having children they they
cost a lot they keep you up at night
they break your heart they inconvenience
you so I would you know looking at the
West the dramatically falling birth
rates which are getting sort of
dangerously low in some societies I
think connect to this idea of of live
live for the moment
as the father of a two-month-old for the
first time I really appreciate your pep
talk on them
brilliant children are but but you're
right of course
of course you know one of the other
things that has really really troubled
me and bothered me and made me question
many things that have been happening uh
in in the anglosphere particularly in
recent decades is what has happened to
the concept of Truth Now obviously when
you have a religious Society truth is
given to you from above do you believe
and look I say this you know France
neither Francis or I are believers
particularly but
I'm just questioning whether is it
possible is it the natural consequence
of the disconnection of religion from
society that you then erode the concept
of Truth or is that something separate
that's happened for different reasons
yeah it's an interesting question and of
course opinions divided on that if you
if I don't know if you've ever had
Stephen Pinker on the show but Stephen
pink is an atheist and he would make a
strong case for truth and a strong case
for Morality and and ethics even though
he denies any any sacred order uh I
think I would have to say that if you if
you reject the sacred if you reject God
I'm not saying that you have to devolve
into the kind of pragmatic
utilitarianism that tends to rule the
day-to-day but you you're presenting
yourself with
a different and a somewhat difficult
challenge if you like you you're going
to have to think long and hard about
that and certainly in a world now again
to return to the technology issue this
is made
far more difficult by by technology
because now we're all able to to pick
and choose the news we receive uh we're
able to buffer ourselves against views
that we may disagree with uh we're able
to cut ourselves off from from
alternative
viewpoints and I think that creates this
this sort of in the public sphere
creates this Anarchy of competing voices
where there is no consensus on Truth
everybody does have their own truth and
it raises the question of of what can we
build a coherent Society on at the
moment
um one could look back to the 19th
century and and I've I've used the
example of the Civil War in this in
class you know there's a serious
disagreement in in the United States
over whether slavery is moral or immoral
whether it's acceptable or not what's
interesting about that debate is that
both sides appeal to the same Authority
they're both typically going back to the
Bible now that doesn't mean they agree
on what the Bible says but I think in a
situation where you have an agreement on
the authority you have some hope of
persuading the other side or reaching
some sort of mutual consensus uh we lack
we lack that today
Carl back in the sort of the early
noughties there was a sort of new
atheist movement wasn't there you know
the the Sam Harris's and the Richard
Dawkins people who we both admire
greatly and you know great thinkers
but and maybe it's a little bit unfair
of me to say this but it looking back it
always struck me as a little bit
arrogant this sort of we don't need
religion anymore religion's stupid we
have science we have logic we have
reason but the thing is science logic
and reason isn't isn't going to comfort
you when you have grief It's Not Gonna
Give You Solace when you feel lost or
emptiness or you're out of control
I mean how do we reconcile those things
I I think you make you a good point and
of course uh historically that
the thinkers who emerge in Germany and
to some extent in in Britain in the
aftermath of the French Revolution saw
that you know the French Revolution was
supposed to be this great exercise where
reason would finally liberate uh and yet
you you read the accounts of the French
Revolution even by those who were
sympathetic to its goals like Mary
Wollstonecraft and you realize no it led
to to terrible Bloodshed you move into
the 20th century and you look at uh the
sort of marxist attempts to rebuild
Society I know the new atheist story
very big and then in some ways
justifiably so on on the Bloodshed that
Christianity left in its wake the
Inquisition for example but yeah more
people were being slaughtered in
Stalin's Russia on any given day of the
week than in the whole history I think
of the the Inquisition in Europe so
there's a lot of evidence that trying to
build on on pure principles of Reason uh
doesn't doesn't work that as you say
human beings are more we're more than
and that's why in the aftermath of the
French Revolution you get thinkers like
Friedrich Schiller in Germany and
Schiller's wrestling with this problem
of how do we make people moral and he
said you know we can't do it just by
reason because people are also emotions
they're also affections uh and we
understand that I I think if you if you
look out the window and you see somebody
being mugged and you have to Google what
to do or you have to reflect on what
should I do in this situation we'd say
you're a psychopath there's something
wrong with your Marathi no you feel you
feel immediate empathy for that person
and you move to help them so Schiller I
think is is correct and so we can't do
this by reason we also have to have our
emotions properly attuned and I think
that's what the new atheists missed that
they were generally good upright
relatively moral people they were not
advocating genocide or anything like
that
but they over
they over overreached in what they
thought that that getting rid of
religion would do uh human beings strike
me as creatures
that want to worship something
s are better to worship than others it
has to be said
hey Constantine do you want better
mental health I'm from Russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink Vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the Bear's feelings it's
Russian Bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about Doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is Western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my ADHD
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink Vodka feel better better help
is customized online therapy to offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p.com
slash trigger
and I I would also uh sort of modify the
argument slightly about uh the new
atheist because I think quite a few of
the people who were the head of that
movement were quite capable of being
inspired by nature and comforted by the
beauty of the Galaxy and all of that
it's just when that ideology on that
worldview is applied to everybody then
you find out that not everybody can
worship those things or take comfort
from them yeah and I think that that was
also made perhaps a flaw in their
approach yeah I was going to say Rich
some of Richard Dawkins writings on the
beauty of nature remarkable yeah quite
quite remarkable exactly and I think
actually all of us are capable of being
inspired and comforted by those things
but uh does that make for the most
cohesive society that that's really the
question that we're we're addressing
here
so with that all in mind where obviously
you talk about technology and that's
something I've been thinking more and
more about how many of the social
movements that we think about as as
being these great steps forward or
backwards or sideways or whatever we're
actually not social movements at all
they were legitimizing the technological
change that had happened already the
sexual Revolution being one of them for
example right we are now living through
a period where I would argue the pace of
change is extraordinary and completely
unprecedented yeah
how do we cope with what is happening
how do we find a route through this
yeah I mean you're you're pointing to
something very uh very significant and I
think I'd sort of come at that in two
ways would say first of all uh
technology itself has shifted the way we
we think there's a famous essay by the
German philosopher Heidegger uh the
question of Technology where he he makes
a point there's a difference between
building a bridge across a river and
damning the river up to generate
electric power and I think the point
he's trying to make is this the bridge
respects nature
the dam is exerting control over nature
and I think we move we've moved very
much in the last century into technology
being part of our control of nature
rather than working with improving upon
respecting nature so that's one thing
that I think plays into the early part
of our conversation the the sort of the
god-like powers we're giving ourselves
the the phenomena you're pointing to in
terms of the speed is is what the the
German
a critical theorist heart mud Rosa
called social acceleration
and it it's it helps explain I think why
a lot of us feel all at Sea you know I'm
so glad that when we came on air today
my it didn't take us too long to sort
the microphones out because technology
leaves me behind all the time uh social
acceleration is is really the argument
that what's happening at the moment is
technological developments are happening
at a speed that Society is not able to
reorganize itself around them before the
next development comes along if we go
back in history to the Reformation to
show you how serious this is you could
argue and that the Reformation is my
area you could you could make an
argument that the Reformation is
you know large part the result of a
technological innovation the printing
press right suddenly power shifts to the
written word people start to become more
literate people start to become more
politically self-conscious well the
Reformation leads to 150 years of bloody
conflict in Europe before things settle
down and one could say that one
technological innovation created such
social disturbance
that you had 150 years of of bloody
conflict as a result moved to the
present day we're getting developments
like the printing press
it seems every few months almost uh
how is society to
adapt accommodate itself be transformed
by these when the next one comes quick
on its heels
every couple of years I have to learn a
new software package or whatever
institution I've worked at and the
software package just generally don't
seem to improve on the old grade books I
like to use with the fans in bed but I
have to learn them and I'm disoriented
and and it throws me out it takes up
time it it makes me grumpy etc etc
that's just a trivial example these
things are happening in in society at a
great speed that as you you point to
inevitably leads us I think disoriented
confused angry resentful a lot of our
political pathologies are not
unconnected to to what we're observing
and can we learn something from the
period of the reformation and because I
mean one of the things that I've talked
about this as well of course the
printing press was wasn't just a new
technology it was a very similar
technology to the ones that we now have
in terms of accelerating the spread of
information in terms of bringing new
people into the political sphere in
terms of emphasizing divisions that
perhaps lay latent prior to that is
there something that modern humans can
learn from that period sure I think
there are a couple of things one I think
we can learn well first of all we could
we can learn what to expect and I think
that there's a sense in which yeah we
can expect all kinds of we can't
necessarily predict what they will be
but we can expect disruptions
transformations to be taking place in
the next 50 to 100 years that could
cause significant uh social upheaval hey
one of the examples I would point to and
we can explore this later if you want
would be the concept of the nation state
States and national identity I think is
being transformed by the internet the
second thing and the broader lesson I
think we can learn from it is is to
realize that you know technology never
just allows us to do the same things
faster it doesn't just make the same
world cleaner and more efficient
what it does is it fundamentally
transforms the world
technology is not the way we we you know
it's not a tool for addressing the world
it's the very medium through which we
experience the world and I think that's
one of Heidegger's points that you know
you you when you change technology you
change the world uh you you don't you
know remember those days perhaps you
guys are too young but I was told you
know email is going to be great because
you're going to spend less time on
correspondence now because you don't
have to write letters you just get the
email and you and your email response
it'll all be done within 15 minutes of
arriving at work or in the day and you
get on with the day's work that's not
how it's happened email correspondence
is not written correspondence only on a
screen email correspondence has a vast
volume and a chaos to it that written
correspondence never had so I think
that's the second thing we can learn
from the Reformation technology doesn't
just tweak part of the world where we're
living in it fundamentally changes the
whole world that we live in
and
isn't it also the problem as well that
we have come to start worshiping
technology
yes again we can see that in how we
think of uh uh uh
prior well I'm trying to think of a
non-contentious example
come on let's go contentious okay back
to the trans we go here we go you guys
are breaking with your uncle
uncontroversial reputation no no our
reputation is uh anything but
uncontroversial I've read I've read the
tweets online so
um I mean think of for example and I'll
I'll try to be as sensitive as I can
this but think of the AIDS crisis of the
1980s one of the things that was
interesting to me when I was doing the
research for the self book was I read
quite a bit on the history of the AIDS
uh epidemic which of course was tragic
and it it destroyed a lot of young lives
and to an extent we still live with with
the with the wounds and the scars of
that to to the present day one of the
things that interested me was that in
the early days of the AIDS epidemic the
gay uh a community was itself sort of
divided over how to handle it there were
those who were pressing for what became
the dominant way of dealing with it and
that's the technological solution we
need greater access to condoms we need
safe sex we need to develop antivirals
as quickly as possible etc etc there was
another group though within the movement
that was pressing for a fundamental
change in Behavior closing down of the
California bath houses which were sort
of hot beds of of anarchic sexual
behavior and become sort of nodal points
for transmission of the disease what's
interesting is that that second group
were pretty quickly marginalized and
then written out of the narrative and
that's interesting because you could
step back and say well in some senses
what you have there is is a battle
between a moral vision
and a technological vision and the
technological Vision one uh it's the
same in the abortion debate today which
of course has exploded in the last few
weeks uh over here in in the United
States that uh the abortion debate is
divided between those who want to see uh
pregnancy as something that involves a
natural obligation between the mother
and the child and therefore has to be be
framed your pregnancy always has to be
dealt within in those kind of moral
terms and those who operate with a view
of of autonomy that says no the until
the child reaches a certain stage or is
Born the the child is merely part of the
woman's body and therefore what you have
here is a technical problem not a moral
problem because we're only dealing with
one person and therefore what we're
dealing with is is merely a a function
of Health Care not of interpersonal
relations and the kind of moral
questions that come in there so there
would be two examples where there tends
to be a default uh in large parts of
society towards seeing what would
traditionally have been regarded as
moral issues now really as as
technological ones
and the thing is is that we expect
technology to be able to solve all of
our problems yeah but it can't it's it
simply can't because life presents
problems that are far deeper and more
complex than that yes I mean technology
yeah
if you fall out with your wife
if you committed adultery if you get
divorced if relations break off with
your children
technology offers no answer to those and
then I would regard those as you know
whether you're religious or not I think
to me those are the big questions of
life
uh I teach the course at College where
part of the focus is supposed to be on
epistemology and I make the you know the
how we know things and I make the points
the students is you know we can look at
epistemology and it's interesting but
bottom line is unless you teach
epistemology for a living nobody gets
out of bed in the morning for
epistemology we get out of bed because
of the things we love the things we hate
things we desire the things we want to
be rid of and Technology doesn't as you
rightly point out doesn't offer answers
to those big questions of life if we
could put it bluntly say in the realm of
medicine technology can tell you how to
save a life
but it cannot explain to you why the
life is worth saving
yeah one could put it as bluntly as that
yeah which means actually the covert
thing interesting because I don't know
what was like in the United Kingdom but
I never saw a moral philosopher being
interviewed about covid prevention and
mitigation strategy it was always the
technocrats the Medical technocrats
it's interesting that you bring up covid
um because I thought that a large part
of our hysterical reaction to it came
from the fact that we don't talk about
death anymore right we don't we don't we
can't accept the fact that we are mortal
that our time on this planet is limited
and it's become a taboo subject and all
of a sudden you have a pandemic that
comes along that suddenly reminds us of
this yeah and we have a meltdown yeah
and the only resource we have is to
double down on the technology we need
this mad scramble to get antivirals
vaccines and mass and by the way I'm not
making any you know I I I think all
those things served a good purpose I'm
not sort of saying those are a bad thing
but they're only part of the issue uh
Anna and I think you're right that again
it goes back to that what technology
teaches us to think about the world
technology teaches us to think we're in
control
and every now and then
nature bites back and reminds us we're
not in control and now we don't have the
resources to handle that other than
panic and a doubling down on
technological efforts
that's a really interesting point
because I suppose one of the things that
comes with that illusion of control is
an inability to deal with the fact that
life comes back and bites you as you say
and so where actually it seems to me at
least less prepared as individuals and
as a society for dealing with setbacks
for dealing with shocks we saw for
example with the reaction to the
invasion of Ukraine uh so many people
were shocked by it and to me as a
Russian it was entirely predictable of
course but I'm not even talking about
that I'm talking about the fact that
things like war and disease which have
been a constant through human history
and essentially are to be expected are
now treated as these gigantic paradoxes
and they must be explained and no one
has the answer and no one has the
solution uh people sort of even even the
conversation we were having about how do
we deal with the invasion of Ukraine it
was fascinating to me how many people
thought that what we need to do is
somehow assassinate Vladimir Putin as if
like turning off one human being solves
the problem of a huge country which has
a movement within it which is intent on
expansion and blah blah blah blah blah
but we just go oh here's a piece of
technology we switch this person off
done yeah and again I think that goes
back to something you you mentioned
earlier that right at the start the
history is important
because the way we behave is also shaped
by the stories we tell about ourselves
the way we think of ourselves and that
you know you're going to Russia Ukraine
you know one can try to explain that
conflict in terms of a single-minded
evil megalomaniac but I think you you
know you and I know that that that's not
adequate one's got to think about the
whole concept of holy Russia one's got
to think about the relationship between
the two Nations but it's got to think
about the the aftermath of the the 1917
Revolution there are all these things
that play into how uh individual people
and Nations think about themselves that
that show us once again that the
technocratic solution is is not the
answer and I think it's why for example
brexit or even the election of Donald
Trump over here was met with such
incomprehension by what I would regard
as the sort of the technocratic class
uh the the progressives they they
couldn't see
any reason on God's Good Earth why
brexit might be seen as a good thing or
why Donald Trump might be seen as
preferable to Hillary Clinton uh it was
very interesting to me that you know you
look at the cities in the United States
the east coast and the West Coast cities
where all of the the technocrats live
cannot understand that big mass in the
Middle where the rural people live the
people who have strong ties to the soil
strong ties to their national and local
narratives none of that can be
technologically explained away
relativized or dismissed and it's very
very powerful in shaping human behavior
it's a great Point Cole because when you
think of a lot of the people you know
David goodheart spoke about this who
voted you know for voted remain or those
people who vote to Hillary Clinton they
tend to be masters of technology which
means they can effectively take their
laptop and work anywhere therefore they
don't have that deep connection
therefore they're not as bound to their
community
yeah I I think that's that's absolutely
correct you might say that you know
globalization has favored the corporate
technocratic class and it's left the
rural agrarian agricultural class behind
uh and and it's also led to this this
Mutual incomprehension uh between
between the two
um yeah I think that's a very very
important point and it's something that
it it's breaking down the traditional
division between right and left it was
interesting to me in 2016 when Bernie
Sanders the very left-wing presidential
candidate pulled out of the the race uh
a significant chunk of his supporters
transferred to Trump
and that was interesting because there
was a kind of populist uh almost native
strand to to Bernie Sanders that if you
just look at it through the lens of
capitalists versus socialists are all
right versus old left you you simply
don't understand what's going on
technology is is remaking the class
system for one of a better term and Carl
uh we talked a little bit about religion
and Francis sort of asked you a question
which may mean that people assume that
he is religious which is not uh but uh
what has been the role of the church and
all of this because I don't know what
the the case in America is very
different of course but here in the UK
the church is becoming a smaller and
smaller part yeah of Our Lives it's
having less and less of an impact it's
less and less relevant
um you know does the church sort of have
to take some responsibility for
abandoning the flock in this great time
of need I think the church is is reaping
to to some extent the the harvest of
what it's sown of course in in Britain
and on on the continents it goes back to
the first year you go back to the first
world war the connivance of the church
in in what I did a special project on
the first world war and in high school
uh grammar school and I couldn't really
tell you what it's about uh I I think
the church was worked hand in glove with
the establishment and when the old
establishment sort of fell or was
exposed as corrupt the church kind of
fell with it so the situation is
different in America because there's
still even now with church the church is
declining rapidly in influence but
they're still a significantly higher
proportion of Americans would identify
as religious typically Christian and
Protestant of one sort or another than
you'd find in in Britain I think the
church has
I I I might say in Britain the church
has reaped the uh has reaped the the
harvest of having identified itself too
closely
with dubious uh Earthbound and worldly
policies rather than focusing on what it
what it what it should do and that is
the worship of of God uh that would take
a long time to unpack but I think you're
on to something that the church is not
simply the victim in this the church is
to us to a significant extent the victim
of itself
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview did you know that you can ask
guests your questions that's right when
you join our local community not only
will you know who we're about to
interview you have the opportunity to
ask them your questions you have the
chance to ask Jordan Peterson the
co-founder of Extinction Rebellion Nigel
farage Douglas Murray Andrew Doyle Jeff
norcott Simon Evans Larry Elder David
bediel Andrew Sullivan Megan Kelly Julia
Hartley Brewer Lord Nigel Lawson Brett
Weinstein inaya for lareniman Dr David
Nutt Jimmy Dore Gad sand Blair white
Melissa Chen Trevor Phillips I am Hersey
Ali Glenn Lowry Bridge effort to see Jim
Rickards Carl Benjamin and so many more
plus we're about to interview some of
the biggest guests in the world we can't
name them just yet but trust me they're
huge me to metaphorically speaking not
just because they're American our locals
gives you access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well on the higher
tiers you get monthly supporter calls
and the opportunity to have a meal or a
call with us click the link below or
com and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com we'll see you
there
and we see now and I wanted to get your
thoughts on it as well because uh we
know we're seeing increasingly religious
figures whether that's the Archbishop of
Canterbury or other senior religious
figures in this country weighing in on
issues of policy or of of
environmentalism or culture or you know
expressing opinions about quite
contentious topics that don't have
anything to do with the primary function
of the church which is to connect to
facilitate the connection between human
beings and the Supreme Being if you like
if you're a religious person which I'm
not but I'm still curious about this
because it seems to me a phenomenon that
is reflective of a general feeling that
every institution now has to be
expressly political yeah and and the
church is probably the one that I would
have expected resisted that the longest
what do you make of that yeah it's
interesting I think that to some extent
that comes from the church Church even
and I think we you know this would apply
to the archery for Canterbury in a way
that it may not apply to your local
Baptist Church uh Minister the
Archbishop of Canterbury still
presumably thinks that he's a
significant public figure and therefore
should opine on these issues problem is
of course when you when you when you
opine on issues that I would regard
people of good faith and I mean Faith
there in not in not in the religious
sense but in in the gens of of well
meant sincerity where you opine on
issues where people of good faith can
legitimately disagree because they read
the evidence differently or see the
solution differently when a religious
leader opines on that you shift the
issue into the realm of sort of one of a
better term sin and transgression
essentially saying anybody who disagrees
with me is actually committing
themselves to sin and evil at this point
and I think that's real problematic move
for church leaders to make on a whole
host of issues so I think there's yeah
the church
when the church opines in public on
issues of public policy
it's its opinion should be
infrequent short and lacking in policy
details I would say if it's to to remain
helpful
um I I do think that the you know what
is the Christian position on the basic
rate of income tax in 2022
uh do social programs uh help the poor
or hinder the poor these are questions
that I think people can legitimately
disagree over people well well-meaning
thoughtful people can disagree over it
doesn't help when church leaders start
to Wade in and you know make these
things you know one down from the the
teaching on the resurrection or
something in importance
Carl but isn't the problem and
with technology that technology has now
turned us all of us into political
figures everybody is now political he's
political I'm political our producer is
political you go to Starbucks you pick
up a rainbow cup my coffee is now
political yeah is it any surprise that
the church has now waded into politics
no no I don't think it's a surprise I
think it's a bad move I don't think it's
a surprise and I think you're pointing
there again to a couple of other things
that have happened in our society one
technology has really abolished private
space uh it used to be that the opinions
I hold about issues a b and c uh well my
employer wouldn't necessarily even know
about them unless I care to express them
to him now of course you find positions
where you can be a postman and you
posted something on Twitter that is
nothing to do with your efficiency in
sorting and delivering mail and
everything to do with the Contemporary
pieties of the modern world and you
could find yourself facing disciplinary
action at work because there's no
private space in order to express those
things anymore the other side of it is I
I view corporate wokeness very very
cynically you know uh yeah is Starbucks
really concerned about these things no I
think Starbucks is concerned about
marketing itself in accordance with the
the memes uh the pathologies the trends
uh that respond to certain kinds of
marketing at the moment
on my keep fit app I I was told last
year that um I you know I got a little
notice on my keep fit app saying you
know we're we're not racist or something
it's kind of well I'm delighted to know
that but I'm a little more concerned
that the you know you keep fit at work
sufficiently you know I kind of assume
they probably weren't racist I wasn't
sure why they felt the need to tell me
but that kind of performative virtue now
I I think it's a marketing scam by a
biology the big corporations
there and you can see that by the way
whatever the flavor of the month is next
month they'll be jumping on that
bandwagon as if they've always been
committed to it
but it is again a form of religion isn't
it because if you go against that you
know and you can say it's marketing and
I agree with you but it's more there's
something else going on because if you
dare question that even if you're a gay
man who questions pride month yeah I
mean you're likely to lose your job
you're likely to be ostracized you're
likely to be treated as a heretic yes we
have our own equivalent to the
Inquisition today only it's much far
much more far-reaching and I think uh
often much more ruthless in the in the
way it operates uh you're absolutely
right and one of the interesting things
for me over the last year or two has
been the fact that you know gay white
males I think are now only one step
above white straight males in the in the
sort of political hierarchy uh it's
fascinating how you know yesterday's
poster child marginalized victim is is
moving rapidly into the the realm of
being an oppressor I think you've had
Andrew Sullivan on this program great
example you know 10 12 years ago he was
a Cutting Edge advocate for gay marriage
now he's a heretic because he doesn't
feel sexually attracted towards women
who transition addition to being there
that puts him Beyond The Pale
what a time to be living in um I I want
to see if we can find some positives or
some remedies at least to to the moment
that we're in
if if what we're facing is a period like
the Reformation but perhaps accelerated
even more so we've talked about the fact
that we ought to expect rapid changes
and and difficulties in in the times to
come and that the technology will uh
change how we view the world you are
someone who has children and
grandchildren now uh as a new father
myself I'm often thinking and I know a
lot of people are thinking about this
how do we raise children in this
environment how do we protect our own
minds from many of the things that are
happening because look let's be honest
we all want to profit and benefit and
whatever from the technology this show
wouldn't be possible if the of the new
technology didn't exist so we want to
take advantage of it but we also want to
protect ourselves and mitigate some of
the negative consequences how does one
charter path through all of this in a
way that allows you to remain sane
that's a very good question uh and under
I think in numerous aspects to any any
answers it's going to be remotely
adequate so I think first of all you're
absolutely right technology is not an
unmitigated evil it's great to live with
I mean
I hope this never happens but if if
you're your newborn child suddenly
develops an illness uh the child stands
a much greater chance of surviving now
than than 200 years ago you know wander
around a graveyard and look at the
number of Graves of newborn and small
children that are there from you're
really cheering me up well thanks mate
I'm just saying it's great that you live
at a time when you you know you're
starting a 50 50 chance now you know
your child reaching 12 years old now
seriously I think technology
what are you doing
I I think being aware that technology is
not an unmitigated good is good as well
because it will allow you to uh you know
I I use the word police advisedly it
will allow you to police your child's
use of technology I I advise parents if
they do not buy your child a smartphone
they don't buy their own when they leave
home but don't buy them a smartphone
because then the most influential people
in your child's life are going to be the
nut cases right left and all points in
between operating on Tick Tock and
YouTube and places like that you know
you you don't want to allow any anybody
direct access into your child's life to
shape the way they think so be aware of
be aware of the problem
then I think and I'm encouraged with
some of the students I teach
undergraduate students I teach on this
learn to appreciate true friendship and
true community
yeah one of the lines I use at the
beginning of my Humanities course at
college is here what if part of the
answer to the meaning of life is not an
idea
what if it's sitting on your deck of an
evening
sharing good conversation and a glass of
wine with a group of good friends
what if that's part of the meaning of
life
one of the things that I think we've
really lost uh is is the notion of
friendship
it's one of the reasons I think there's
so many I don't know if it's what it's
like in the United Kingdom but in the
United States a large number of young
teenage girls are identifying as
bisexual lesbian now at an age when I
wouldn't even have been aware
particularly of of sexuality and I asked
a teacher recently why do you think you
know the 8 out of 10 girls in your class
identify as lesbian at the age of 12.
and he said because we don't teach them
what friendship is anymore
these kids feel strong feelings for
other kids
and we have given them nothing other
than sexual categories for them to
understand those feelings in that
relationship so I would say teach your
kids what friendship is teach them to
Value not the friends who they don't
really know on Facebook or whatever
friends in the local neighborhood
I I really believe that one of the great
opportunities at this current moment is
for those who get what's going on we can
work at rebuilding community and
friendship
refocusing ourselves on the people that
we rub shoulders with day by day I I
think Hospitality cultivating
hospitality and friendship is a great
opportunity great opportunity that that
lies before us at this point much to
lament and worry about in the situation
we find ourselves but
let's think about for example what
marginalization has historically done to
groups the Jews in the Middle Ages uh
the Quakers in the 19th century
they became strong communities their
marginalization was not simply for them
an opportunity to sit around and feel
sorry for themselves
it became an opportunity for building
real friendships real Community bonds so
I think even though the odds are really
stacked against that kind of thing one
of the great and beautiful things that
we can do at this point is model in a
small way in the street we live in in
the families that we have
true Community have dinner on the dinner
table four or five times a week not in
front of the television invite people
over to your house have drinks on your
deck and find conversation
show people what real friendship and
real Community is
that's a really really powerful because
thought because here's the thing and
this is why I feel so worried about this
technology Carl people talk about online
communities isn't it it's not a
community it's not a community it's not
a community it's an illusion yeah you
know it's we've been sold this idea of
connection that's talking to someone on
Facebook is not a connection yeah a
connection is when you sit down with
someone literally in front of you it's
not when people use this that this term
that I hated during the pandemic we met
on Zoom I'm like you didn't [ __ ] me
on Zoom yeah you've never met sorry
I'm glad to be a therapist for you guys
I'll send you my bill later but uh uh no
I think you're right and one of the
things I think the pandemic taught a lot
of people is
bodily contacts quite important you may
have met on Zoom but you'd rather have
met in person
uh and you know one of the most
heartbreaking pictures of the whole
pandemic was uh that picture of that the
funeral of that little Muslim boy
that made it made the headlines over
here I think he died from covid isolated
an award his parents weren't allowed to
visit him and then he was buried and the
funeral there was just this tiny little
coffin the Imam I think and a coffin
Bearer his parents couldn't even be at
his funeral
and I defy anybody
think about that situation and think
that was right and appropriate no it
wasn't no child no child should die let
alone die alone without the voice of
their mother telling them they love them
without holding their hand that was
heartbreaking I think when we when we're
confronted with things like that we
didn't realize wow
this is dehumanizing and why is it
dehumanizing
because we lack bodily context I haven't
seen my mum uh physically for three and
a half years I'm coming back to the UK
in a couple of weeks I call my mum every
couple of weeks and it's great to hear
her voice but nothing will be sitting in
the front room and having a cup of tea
with her because bodily presence is
important so I think you're getting to
another thing there yeah the
disembodying nature of technology is
also a dehumanizing part of Technology
so yeah I agree with you entirely I
think the the comments you've made uh
towards the end are absolutely perfect
in terms of having some sort of vision
of how to navigate these times uh Carl
we always end our interviews with uh one
question which I feel you are uniquely
placed to answer well which is what is
the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be
yeah I think
the one thing is what is all this doing
to children
what is all of this stuff doing to
children
that to me has to lie at the heart of
it's one thing for adults to do whatever
they want to do
but I think we have a responsibility to
our children and to our grandchildren
you know you may not be a believer
that's okay we may not share the same
moral vision for things it's okay but I
think
everybody should be in agreement that
our responsibility is ultimately not to
ourselves
it is to our children
and it's that I think that needs to
inform the debates about everything from
you know from adoption to the
environment and I'm not preempting what
our conclusions on those things should
be but I'm thinking I I don't hear
children referred to as anything but
political footballs or collateral damage
at this particular point in our public
discourse I think we need to we need as
adults to realize our responsibility
lives to our children and that needs to
be at the heart of the ethical and moral
debates that are taking place in society
were fantastic we have got a couple of
questions for you from our local
supporters which only they will see in a
second but for now the book is a the
rise and Triumph of the modern self I
recommend people get it where else
should people find your work online Carl
generally I write for I write for a
magazine called First Things uh every
two weeks I have a column there
firstthings.com
and that's uh generally so it's
conservative and religious but not
distinctively Christian site there are
Jewish writers as well and the
occasional Muslim writer actually so
firstthings.com would be to where where
you could find most of my my online work
fantastic well thank you so much for
being with us and thank you for watching
and listening we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or Russia they always go out at 7
p.m UK time and for those of you who do
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
[Music]
sent religion which is the environment
we're operating now how does one
cultivate restraint in oneself
thank you
[Music]
foreign